qu'est ce que je cherche secrètement à
casser ce fonds vert pour en racheter un
parce que gelée depuis déjà trois ans et
qu'ils commencent à s'user
aujourd'hui on va parler des professeurs
des professeurs qu'ils ont quand même
capable de changer une vie une
adolescence plutôt voir une vie en vrai
je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde a des professeurs qui sont mieux
que ce que moi j'avais à l'époque après
comme on dit l'herbe du voisin est
toujours plus verte que la sienne quand
je peux qu'aller une expression jeu-là
kalou sur sa bosse métier parce que
c'est vraiment transmettre du savoir et
donc trouver la meilleure manière qu'il
soit de le faire alors évidemment il ya
plein de cours qui sont reloués ya plein
de profs qui ont des méthodes ou
globalement les élèves c'est ils sont
pas très stimulés mais il ya des profs
qui font des trucs de malade et y en a
de plus en plus des profs qui vraiment
se disent bon on va essayer de rendre ce
sujet intéressant on va essayer de
toucher la classe en amenant sa d'une
manière spécifique et je trouve ça
génial j'avais un prof d'histoire qui
était tellement passionné d'histoire et
qui s'exprime et tellement bien que l'on
était tous à fond dedans pareil j'avais
une prof de maths j'avais 6 de moyenne
en terminale et elle marchait pas elle a
réussi à me faire raccrocher avec les
maths en ayant certaines techniques en
comparant sa ou jeux vidéo parce qu'elle
savait que je jouais rares jeux vidéo et
tout est au final au bac es juste 18 et
c'est grâce à elle j'ai réussi une prof
d'éco qui avait accepté deux fois que je
sois absent toute une journée parce que
j'avais eu le tournage de plouffe et des
hanches du fps elle aurait dû me retenir
ces deux jours elle ne sait pas ce
qu'elle a engendrée mais c'est pas grave
merci aujourd'hui on va regarder une
petite série de vidéos du genre qui met
en avant des profs ou ce qui se passe
dans les salles de classe j'ai hâte mais
avant c'est le hashtag
rien de mieux qu'un bon bain de soleil
vive les vacances miam oyez oyez glace
et beignets bonjour monsieur vous voulez
quelque chose ça irait nous merci je
suis au régime pour l'anc sommer body
moi je vous trouve très bien comme ça
énorme beau gosse merci je suis flatté
de rien et si vous ne voulez pas manger
je peux vous proposer autre chose comme
des bouées rigolote par exemple ça non
mais j'ai une offre de réduction pour un
abonnement nord vdn
j'aurais jamais cru avoir besoin de ça
bien sûr que si ça permet de chiffrer la
connexion internet et ça protège
également votre navigation sur les sites
web super mais vraiment je suis à la
plage là donc bof et ça ne vous empêche
pas de regarder une petite série sur
votre téléphone north vpn ne peut
fonctionner sur six appareils en même
temps j'aime ou frère qui seraient
contents vous pouvez éviter les
restrictions géographiques en changeant
dit paix et avoir accès à des contenus
qui sont disponibles que dans certains
pays et pour quelles raisons
j'achèterais un vpn un vendeur de
beignets un vendeur de beignets burgos
vous voulez dire oui si vous voulez et
bien car j'ai une super offre grâce à
mon lien en description vous profiterez
d'un abonnement de deux ans avec une
énorme réduction ainsi que d'un cadeau
bonus le cadeau bonus je suppose que
c'est un beignet non promis et c'est
sans risque satisfait ou remboursé
pendant les 30 premiers jours d'accord
vous m'avez convaincu vous pouvez me
mettre de la crème dans le dos
maintenant n'abuse pas beau gosse auquel
est go ok c'est une vidéo avec un prof
de sciences rachat et se passe des trucs
de fou en cours de sciences moi j'avais
pas ce à quoi tu mon prof de svt
monsieur vielle au lycée z comme ça nos
marques nos professeurs c'est dire
l'importance qu'ils ont quand même en
vrai on se souvient de leurs noms des
années des années plus tard je trouve ça
assez ouf j'ai raison de faire cette
vidéo dit le rassurez moi
on dirait un peu mon père s'il était un
peu plus aigri pardon c'est méchant il
va faire quoi
mais d'où
il est fier c'est trop mignon quand je
vois une personne qu'à l'âge de mes
parents et qui est fier qu'à une
expression un peu d'enfants genre
je sais pas faire avec ou sans enfants à
chaque fois je suis touché de fous je
suis méga et j'espère qu'on aura cet âge
là on aura ce truc un peu millions
touchant cette part d'innocence en tout
cas moi pour halloween en cours il se
passait rien cette année je suis sûr
qu'il a des tas de gens qui ont acheté
le truc de squid game là et qui se sont
pensés malin et originaux l'année
dernière vous aviez le déguisement
cazalet papel cette année ce quiz game
on revoir hop là la très bon exemple les
gars c'est halloween il ramène des
citrouilles et montrent une réaction
chimique en se basant sur un truc qui
lie le court halloween c'est beau gosse
je suis désolé il a raison d'être fiers
un classique je les ai pas vus station
de dégâts c'est sam déclare elle me dit
ce truc là tu l'as vu ses cultes c'est
classique sur le web je n'ai jamais vu
je commence à avoir un complexe je ne
suis pas un enquêteur incroyable vous le
savez mais globalement ce n'est pas un
professeur soyons honnêtes au mieux
c'est un surveillant d'ailleurs je le
saurai au vu des 10 la turquie a plein
de dislike est liée à cette réflexion
mais comme youtube les a retirés sous
prétexte de moins toxicité là comment on
fait pour savoir si une vidéo et
mensongères 1
[Musique]
commença à 20 ans ils reprennent la
boulangerie de la rue l'expérience d'un
professeur a mal tourné non mais les
cours de chimie se passe des trucs fous
c'était quoi ce truc le plus fou que
s'est passé - cours de chimie
bah je m'en souviens pas les gars c'est
que c'est pas trés ouf qu'est ce qui va
se passer à la
[Musique]
mais flo leurs cours de chimie c'est
skyrim mois ils projetaient un vieux
spectre des couleurs au tableau ça me
saoule bon là il ya clairement un truc
qui va qui balancent de l'eau en cada
sandy lyle un détecteur lie à un
détecteur de fumée professeur vous savez
faire des boules de feu c'est bien mais
vous ne savez pas détecté un détecteur à
fumer c'est grave
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu un humain être aussi
content de voir de l'eau en vrai de vrai
je pense que le prof il a pris très très
cher pour cette erreur et je suis
dégoûté parce qu'un prof qui fait des
boules de feu les gars c'est rare mon
professeur de maths dessine son visage
sur ta copie si tu as eu bon à
l'exercice
au sart est égal on dirait pas il va
lancer une chaîne de fast food de
poulets frits non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai option qui testent le futur logo de
cette chaîne de fast food du métro mon
professeur était excité de notre course
sur la première guerre mondiale bon je
veux pas être méchant mais c'est un
écran de projecteur la carte tu pouvais
la projeter un tu veux quoi tu veux des
compliments là à tout va c'est comme le
mot de l'histoire du médecin là dans les
hôpitaux qui a injecté des trucs qui
créent des arrêts cardiaques chez les
patients et derrière il est réanimé
passer pour un héros toi c'est pareil
cette carte tu pouvais l'a projeté
au j'ai tellement pas en victime en
gueule je vous jure ça me fait cet effet
là elle voir des preuves pas donc
elle comprend pas une copie à salah gas
vous avez [ __ ] sa journée là vous
qu'étudier mal regardé comme vous avez
indiqué sa journée on regarde il est
son rôle non mais les gars ce langage
corporel fabien olicard tu peux faire
une analyse de 4h30 là dessus tu vas te
régaler mon frère au petit chien kohl's
et chat pas compris la trappe
franchement frérot lui tu les coudes
pendant un an une fois qu'il a fait ça
danse vraiment tu lui fais des
compliments sur son short tu dis même
que l'époque où il avait des cheveux
c'était moins bien commun enfin tu
deviens vraiment un bon gros faux culs
quoi tellement il force le respect
angres entre de physique mais eux ils
sont hors catégorie déjà eu il s'amuse
pas des professeurs ils viennent avec
des produits chimiques qui créent les
explosions des boules de feu excuse moi
mon vieux mettez un sorcier en fait et
par un professeur là c'est une
compilation de ce que un professeur de
physique a fait pendant tout un
trimestre il a apparemment 70 ans il
fait tout ça pour ses étudiants pour
leur transmettre un peu la passion de la
physique-chimie
[Musique]
attendait la fesse boulet
il se met en scène alors qu'il a 70 ans
et probablement doctorat en physique
chimie ça a mal fini
les frire vous fais attention soixante
dix ans si tu peux te blesser facilement
mais en fait vous allez faire des one
man show à l'époque il ya malentendu il
se met en scène il en a rien à [ __ ]
hymne et un bonnet d'âne et saute sur
cet objet même si j'avais un petit frère
et que c'était son anniversaire je
ferais pas ça et rien à [ __ ] à preuve
s'est fait voler ses chaussures donc ses
élèves lui ont fait une surprise a eu
lieu à geler vue ils ont acheté une
paire de chaussures il a pleuré je les
ai vus j'ai chialé avec lui
un non regardez sa réaction aux non non
non
non non non non non non non
je fais j allais non on retire pas les
lunettes non non non
non il ya tellement de gardes que je
vous jure
c'est pas pour ça que je voulais faire
cette vidéo je ne vais pas pleurer mois
on a besoin de plus d'enseignants comme
lui alors pourquoi les trois quarts des
professeurs homme qu'on vient de voir
nos plans de cheveux c'est une vraie
question surtout ceux de physique chimie
c'est quoi à force de faire des boules
de feu ils sont brûlé les cheveux qu'est
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
il a peint plus gros rond que tout le
monde avec une chercheure prof créer une
explosion en pleine classe c'est une
vidéo des bonnes vibrations ou des gages
en train de poser des questions est ce
qu'ils ont le droit de faire des boules
de feu en classe où est ce qu'ils se
tapent des kiffe ce que quand même il
approche une flamme de faim chez pas
ça va rater
mais
il ya du feu qu'à voler sur des tables
non il dans l'huile a abusé je vous le
dis donc tu t'imagines ce a atterri sur
les cheveux d'un élève bah ça donnera un
professeur de chimie plus tard ce
professeur projette son visage pendant
les examens
les mecs mais t'as craqué ça met une
pression folle déjà que c'est stressant
un examen pour le coup je trouve ça
horrible c'est une paire menaçant un
enfant reçoit la permission de la part
du professeur de manger un fruit pendant
la classe sympa c'est vrai défaut est
autorisée
c'est un troll il va sortire genre un
méga free va sortir une ppl
troll j'adore il a réussi son temps la
perfection regarder la compréhension ou
plutôt la compréhension du il m'a bien
eu qu'elles doivent c'est ce qu'a celi
dans la tête le meilleur professeur ever
arrêté dire le meilleur le meilleur pour
moi c'était le professeur de physique de
70 ans
il va chanter c'est une chance
incroyable
[Musique]
merveilleux oh je me souviens de ma prof
de musique au collège qui nous faisait
chanter du queens et jeter passée au
tableau j'avais fait ma ma
à québec
alors oui moi
ouais on est suivi doit 25 millions de
vues et devinez quoi je les ai pas vus
comme d'hab' tout ce qui est culte etc a
beaucoup tourné sur le web s'est passé à
côté de moi est ce le professeur le plus
cool du monde arrêté on l'a trouvée
c'est lui
et danses tous trop bien
pourquoi ils vont tous trouvé tout seul
il a appris à 700 élèves une routine de
danse
il est trop fort il s'est dit bon je
vais leur donner les cartes en main pour
percer sur tik tok tous comme ça même si
à l'école il s'en sort pas ils s'en
sortiront sur tik tok grâce à la danse
il a tout prévu qu'elle bosse on finit
avec un prof qui trollent sur serveur il
a mis un fichier qui s'appelle quatrième
trimestre réponse clés au quiz entre
parenthèses ne pas poster évidemment
quand les élèves clic
gâteries crohn
médias s'il était professeur jeffrey que
ça je trouverais tellement tout le temps
les élèves mais je pense que ça leur
ferait du mal à l'arrivée mais quel kiff
messieurs dames j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu je vois que vous avez qui
fait de voir des professeurs
profondément investi est sympa et ça
existe un partout dans le monde y en a
pleins brève percée va regarder cette
vidéo merci aussi à tous ceux qui ont
précommandé blick là les pré commandes
viennent de se terminer ce complément
des ressources et sa fin janvier les
autres ce sera dispo partout en mars
vous avez été plusieurs dizaines de
milliers à précommander un pacs et les
chiffres qui sont énormes donc merci
beaucoup pour tout soutien alors
j'espère évidemment que la bd vous
plaira et que les packs vous plairont
pour si vous commandez les packs voilà
fallait que j'en parle en fin de vidéo
je vous dis à bientôt portez vous bien
à bientôt soldats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
[Musique]